leider gar nicht deutschland und
hannoversche mal hier seht es bereits im
titel eingeblendet freunde wir versuchen
heute youtube anhand von drei merkmalen
drei nicht 40.000 anhand von drei
merkmalen die uns hier zur verfügung
gestellt werden müssen wir erwarten zu
welchem youtuber die gehören das mache
ich jetzt zum dritten mal tatsächlich
auf meinem kanal viele leute mal wieder
zu
[Applaus]
erkennst du diese youtuber an blaue
lesen und ich dachte gerade welcher
youtuber steht in verbindung mit blau
ein buch
einem fahrkartenautomaten richtig
von crafter falls ihr euch übrigens
fragt was es mit diesem glücksrad auf
sich hat bleibt einfach bis zum ende des
videos dran
dieses quiz ist vom wissens automatisch
um
das bin ich direkt die erste person bin
ich bist du richtig
ich meine klar lee pizza so meine pizza
kommt am 15 10 in die supermärkte die
lukasz szukala 15.10 rewe edeka über
deutschland als mal an die natürlich ein
smiley als logo student bin ich
mittlerweile nicht mehr aber das ist
auch schon fast machen wir allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten youtuber
live hacks schwarze haare und türke
emrah ist der einzige der live hacks
macht eigentlich und ja freunde ssm ra
wollt ihr dass sich mit emma vielleicht
was meine pizza rache wir hatten das
überlegt wenn die rauskommt dass wir
dazu
wollt ihr das schreibt in die comments
nächster youtuber freunde paar prüfungen
verhauen fitness und verarscht youtuber
nico wissens automatismus bisschen
schwieriger sein für mich ins corp 21
freude kann mich noch genau daran
erinnern wie er früher 67 mal die
führerscheinprüfung mich bestanden hat
dsds make up und blond das ist schirin
david okay wenn ich nicht alles richtig
haben sollte werde ich 40 millionen euro
runterschlucken immer mit der ruhe
so viel geld habe ich nicht mal nächster
youtuber den wir erraten müssen asiate
jim bäm
die alten sachen müssen was gar nicht
mehr anschauen einhauen wahrscheinlich
ich stehe heute komplett neben der spur
also auch hier meine damen und herren
haben wir als auflösung julien genau
machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten youtube an bisher mir wirklich
jeden richtig rap ist nicos range rover
range rovers habe ich mittlerweile nicht
mehr
er wird geklaut oder so aber es ist
akkurat jetzt müsst ihr noch irgendwas
stehen von wegen fortnight heads videos
oder so aber zu der zeit war das auf
jeden fall dass für das upgrade das ist
bibi du schauen des likes und make up
das wäre eigentlich interessant wenn man
mal überlegen würde wie sich das so
verändern hat bei mir wird
wahrscheinlich jetzt zu verstehen wie er
tatsächlich immer noch liebt es mal die
und dann statt studenten wahrscheinlich
einfach vollidiot aber bei baby wird
jetzt wahrscheinlich stehen du schrauben
hochzeit und schwanger oder irgendwie
sowas oder eigenes haus oder keine
ahnung was aber es war auf jeden fall
weg ist petit palace hat mir wieder
richtig blogs minecraft longboard hieß
simon und es gibt mittlerweile wird das
glaube ich einfach nur noch stehen um
geklickt ich weiß habe ich da nicht so
viel von mit krieger ich glaube herr
reagiert ja nur noch auf andere sachen
das tier war natürlich das was ihn
früher ausgezeichnet hat wie gesagt
freunde das video ist ein jahr und einen
monat alt war
no way also real talk das passt viel
viel viel viel mehr zu simon weil dna
meine meinung meines wissens nach erlebt
doch irgendwie seitdem 40 jahren kein
minecraft mehr hoch und longboard ok da
war einmal die longboard vorrunde dabei
und blogs hat simon doch auch eigentlich
hauptsächlich immer gemacht jetzt muss
ich mir wohl 40 millionen euro in mund
stecken also das mit den a konnte ich
nicht so ganz verstehen ich weiß nicht
was jeder auch er bei simon umbau oder
seid ihr auch bei dem das ist also
wirklich das ist echt easy sage ich und
hatte vorhin was falsch kondome brüste
und kein werbe freundlicher content ist
ganz klar mein lieblingslied schülerin
katja glaser witz freunde sehen wir auch
hier war die katja krause wir haben nur
noch einem youtuber glaube ich den wir
erraten müssen freunde commander komplex
und wird
ja es ist es commander krieger war
tatsächlich früher einer meiner
lieblings youtuber den ich wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr gern geschaut hat
mittlerweile habe ich ihn wirklich
irgend wie seit jahren nicht mehr so
richtig was von dem mitbekommen da ist
er unser commander krieger ich weiß
nicht wie viele von euch werden
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr kennen wie
viele youtuber konnte tierarten schreibt
in kommentaren neun habe ich geschafft
das ist eigentlich gar nicht gar nicht
mal so scheiße an der stelle wird das
heutige wird jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren es tut
mir leid dass das heutige video ein
bisschen kürzer war allerdings haben
julia und ich dafür für morgen ein
größeres video geplant und zwar haben
wir uns das hier bestellt das ist zwar
drehen und da sind 14 felder drauf und
hey jude und ich werden auf jedes dieser
14 felder eine andere challenge
aufschreiben also beispielsweise ein
elektroschock kriegen oder löffel senf
essen oder keine ahnung was machen wenn
ihr wollt dass julia und ich damit
morgen ein video hochladen sollen leute
schafft wird sich 1000 likes
bis morgen ihr dürft entscheiden ob er
bock drauf habe sagt eurer katze und
eurer oma beschied sie sollen dann kommt
morgen davon ein riesiges video wie wir
14 challenges machen und immer drehen
wer was machen dies
bis morgen
[Musik]